welcome to the fear assessment test are
you afraid
are you afraid right now
maybe you should be well not yet anyway
we haven't taken the test warning this
test contains materials that may be
harmful or traumatizing to some
audiences
it also may include visual effects it
may harm the viewer please proceed
precede with caution
okay
no
[Music]
all right
oh the fear assessment is a specialized
test developed and implemented by
government agencies to collect data on
psychological torture techniques and
their impact on individuals it serves as
an essential tool in understanding the
effect of fear-based manipulation this
test uses your webcam
does it
does it now I don't know if it's going
to be able to do that because it's kind
of
it's being used but whatever in order to
follow the test to its full extent you
must follow these six rules leave all
doors inside wide open
foreign
[Music]
I gotta leave it
I gotta leave It Wide Open
um
all right I didn't know I needed this
set this up
okay hold on
I plug God I'm gonna unplug my whole
network
oh yeah
it's fine oh
that's fine
it's fine oh God
it's fine I was hating these lights
anyway they're stupid
right out here it's that's a it's a sky
I can't turn that one off the game says
I need to leave all the doors
it says visible doors
no visible door
doors wide open that's what it says
you know that light is much better
actually you know I don't know why why
do I have
this lighting is much better
God damn
all right my vanity is showing okay
anyway God that is that is uncomfortable
I don't like that as much it did say I
need to have a light on my face so I'm
leaving this one light on my face so I
have a lead on my face
these instructions are a little
contradictory because it says turn off
all lights and also have a light on your
face and those are very different things
whatever all right I've done what I can
again I if you're going to use my webcam
I I'm using it right now
I'm using it so you can't use it and
whatever it's not gonna do it all right
you all have to do the same thing too
you got to turn on all your lights
you gotta open the doors that are
visible click on the faces level one
I see your face man that Echo oh boy I
deface
oh
what is that no that's a skeleton I
think I think there's a face there oh
I'm doing great
I face
oh well is that her face
what's on the ground there
all right
hi hey
how you doing
oh is that a face down there
okay
this is the same one
it's it's oh man I'm paranoid
yippee
[Music]
hi
okay
ah well that's nice is that face out
there okay
ah I did it
we will begin the next level in 10
seconds well that's an oddly specific
amount of time
oh
question and answer do you ever feel
like you're being watched
yes literally all the time
have you ever heard a voice call your
name but no one was there
Yes actually I have 100
that goes throwing me off yes
I'm paying attention
listen to the voices my doctor said not
to do that
oh okay
okay I mean oh hey okay I was a little
sick but
hi it's a face
[Music]
oh
interesting if a figure was to appear
from the corner of your room you would I
have a bore spear now admittedly the
boar spear is
let's fix this problem shall we this is
why you keep a bowler spear
engaged at all times I'm gonna just go
ahead and know
let's see this thing
so this is a bore spear now this is used
for spear and bores and uh I'm pretty
sure that uh a Boar's a bit tougher than
any kind of uh wannabe fake person okay
so I'm thinking that a few stabs it is
four spear ought to be just dude
that ought to be enough I'm gonna put
this sheath back on uh because I might
die and also I don't know if you knew
this but if you uh it says do not grip
on the sides when you're putting back on
because the bore spear is so sharp that
it could cut right through the sheath
and you would slide your hands to rivets
oh that's not going in straight oh no
come on
oh boy oh this is this is dangerous okay
hold on everybody
uh
oh boy
oh no
it doesn't want to go back in I think
it's one of those bore Spears where as
soon as you uh unsheath it it has to
taste blood before it can um go back to
sleep here anybody got any boar Blood
come on
air almost there
please it is slicing through this thing
oh do I have it upside down
I know what I'm doing
[Music]
right
right oh
okay
right
here
because if I need to turn around and
yeah
if I just
you can see the y'all sure so if
anything
right right and it's go itself
so quick release pap
okay that's pretty good
okay what was I doing
oh
[Music]
it's very it's very long
uh what was the question
if a figure was to appear from the
corner of your room you would oh pray
for their soul because they're going to
die
[Music]
have you ever thought about being
tortured to death
I think that many okay here's don't hear
me out not a Mascus right but I'm about
to say a very Markiplier is not a maso's
thing I cannot be the only one that has
had this like latent fantasy of having a
heroic death right where it's some okay
like five people are abducted by an
alien right and each of them is put
through horrendous torture and if all of
them give up and surrender then the
world they'll blow up a city right but I
won't I'll I'll die before I give up
because all I want to be the hero and
sacrifice myself it doesn't matter the
pain it doesn't matter the torture I'll
endure anything ignore anything to be a
hero I think that's like a very common
thing right that has to be right
yes do you fear the concept of an
afterlife yeah because I kind of I kind
of like the idea of
Eternity being a terrifying cons concept
who wants to live forever I kind of do
yeah
do you have loved ones
plural yes
do you care for Animals yes that's why
I'm only gonna stab at human height
oh well that was easy I thought I was
gonna have to step
Next Level will begin in 10 seconds sure
okay as if you can count
[Music]
which one oh baby doggy it's right there
ready to Boop and snoot boink
[Music]
right
listen press space if you can't handle
the audio
oh boy
oh oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I was just reminded of the unisonice
video where it's at Church website
and Ethan and I are trying to talk over
it
[Music]
God I'm oh what a good video oh I missed
that one this is like this website is
www.jesusfaves.com
do you have any illnesses demons are
inside you no we don't have any printed
materials oh
oh
well that is nice
oh that was
oh man Amy and I there was a thread on
Twitter that was just people's favorite
doing his honest clips and man uh some
bangers in there
there's some real bangers
ah good times good memories
well this is just Birds
you know
what Jesus will dream you from yourself
you have to pray the demons away oh it
was demonbuster.com that's what it was
demon buster
are you in the website you are currently
on the
www.demonbuster.com was it demon Buster
I don't even remember
I can't remember
oh great good I did it
I don't know what the fear assessment is
gonna say because that made me think of
those things but
we will begin the next level in 10
seconds I don't believe you
[Music]
oh
stop the demons
I can't believe it's working
foreign
that was great
I don't think I played it right but that
was great I think I with this bore spear
in that webcam was Far scarier than
anything they could possibly make but
that's that's not the game developer's
fault that was really a cleverly made
game I am just not a cleverly made
YouTuber uh so I did it all wrong anyway
happy bore Spears to you guys I I'm
gonna sell cloak brand boar Spears very
soon so if you want cloak bore Spears
for all your bore spearing need get
ready because
they're coming leave your doors open
yeah
I was ready